welcome back to las vegas now southwest
medical the sponsors of this next
segment is back to remind you about
medicare annual enrollment period i
spoke to a doctor to learn more
dr goku welcome back thank you so much
you know we're still talking about
medicare enrollment period because we
have until december 7th so let's just
talk about for anyone who's out there
who still doesn't know what this means
what is that annual enrollment period
absolutely medicare annual enrollment is
your time to enroll in or make changes
to your medicare or medicare advantage
health plan and as you said started in
october and it runs only through
december 7.
so what are the important things that
people should keep in mind during this
time i know it's very important
definitely most people want care that
they can access when they need it at a
cost that they can afford medicare
advantage plans offer great value
they're amongst the most valuable
popular and fastest growing plans in the
country three easy steps to follow are
to know your needs personalize your
choices and then choose a plan
perfect and i know southwest medical you
guys have some senior focused
initiatives what are those
we're very passionate about helping
older adults live a healthy and happy
quality lifestyle we have several
programs that focus on keeping our
seniors healthy 24 7 access to telephone
advice nurse line for any of those
questions that arise at any time of day
or night as well as virtual visits that
can be conducted 24 7 from the comfort
of your home also a preventative health
coordinator who can help guide you
through understanding screening
preventative measures and scheduling any
of your visits we also have easy to
access facilities five of our facilities
are complete health care centers which
is everything a patient could need from
primary care to subspecialty care labs
imaging and testing as well as for
neighborhood walgreens locations so that
you can see a provider while you're
picking up a prescription or shopping
wow you guys definitely have us covered
at southwest medical thank you um so if
someone wants to you know ask them last
minute questions what should they do how
can they follow up on this topic yes now
is the best time to learn about your
options you can call your number on your
screen to be connected by the optimum
care network of nevada to a licensed
sale agent to ask more questions and
find out more about your options
all right dr gokul thank you
it was a pleasure
thank you to southwest medical and
associates for sponsoring that segment
they have locations across southern
nevada so call 702 608
for enrollment information or visit
smalv.com